this program features live coverage of
an African safari and may include animal
kills and caucuses viewer discretion is
advised
hello everybody and good afternoon how
awesome is this
with kicking off our Sun that said
safari with awesome is that well welcome
aboard everyone I am Shoshanna and I've
got said on camera with week and we are
of course coming to you from Juma
private game reserve here on the western
fringes of the kruger national park now
do you remember to interact with us and
use the hashtag Safari live on Twitter
or of course the YouTube chat stream to
ask us any questions you'd like about
these lovely Avoca mails that we've got
you now we do have two so we've got this
guy right here who's quite tired as
lions do in the middle of the day find
it a good spot of shade although I think
he could have done a bit better with his
choice of shade but maybe he wants a bit
of Sun on him too absolutely beautiful
and I always love to spend time with
your vocal males because I think that
they're absolutely majestic sound a bit
funny actually my mic is come out yes it
has
there we go I'm sorry if I sound very
funny but I'm just gonna fix this way
hello hello is that better
yay I'm so sorry guys but like I was
saying we're speaking about these Avoca
males so we have the one here and
there's one behind us as well
well not quite behind us a little a
little distance behind us so I will keep
up with them for most of the day I think
today until unless they feel a bit too
sleepy but I don't want to lose them
once the Sun starts to set you see
absolutely standing now this gives you a
really good impression of how these can
be so camouflaged Cheryl you say this is
an amazing stunt I couldn't agree with
you more this is an excellent start I'm
so glad that we found them now you can
see in this in the Rayleigh Brown sort
of dried up grass in the Sun that's
hitting on it these animals are really
well camouflaged something just bothered
him now if we think a wandering about
who we've got yeah he only picked his
head up very briefly so didn't get a
very obvious look at him but he is
either the blond or the dark may invoker
because I think the Mohawk one is behind
us
look at the flick of the tail now it's
really awesome to see these animals in
their natural environment and something
I'm really thankful for because so often
most people see animals like this in
zoos and I mean it's one thing and
they're still absolutely amazing but to
see them in a natural environment
they're choosing to be here and choosing
to sit down right here is just amazing I
love how he swats is himself every now
and then with the little tuft of his
tail
this is very exciting I think I'm as
excited as you guys are I always love to
see them especially when you see their
faces and you think wow what an amazing
animal now for those of you who don't
know the Avoca males are the dominant
coalition in this area and the Lions
that you may be familiar with the Inca
Houmas which is the resident pride here
basically kind of belong to this
coalition and it's three of them we've
got the dark Mane's the blonde mane and
the mohawked male and they were born in
about 2013 you can see they have this
nice big beautiful mane anyway I'm going
to stick around with them of course I am
how could I leave them this is an
excellent start to the show well let me
send you over to James and see if he can
even Trump this
[Music]
I am the ghooost of the wilderness and I
am driving the car today
you can ask any questions you like using
the hashtag Safari live on Twitter or
just think if a question and I will
answer it for you
not really it was me I know you're very
surprised hello welcome to the Sun set
Safari as Josh Allah has explained you
we are gearing up for television
pressure is not quite as profound as it
was last week when we had nothing at the
start of the drive now we've got two
flat lions who will almost certainly
walk West off the reserve at about 29
minutes past 6:00 and Jamie Patterson
will hopefully also be heading towards
befalls Hook waterhole fairly soon to
show you ting Ghana who has been there
for quite some time
Lauren will have been sitting in the Sun
for roughly five hours by the time Jamie
gets there she's been babysitting ting
Ghana and so well we've got a little bit
of cat action at least this afternoon
our plan is to well apart from just
enjoying the very pleasant temperature
of the Sunday afternoon is to head down
sort of around the tree house down area
which is central south and central
central central around the Marty
drainage system because Herbert is on
foot around the area looking for Columba
David there's the animal that you and I
will remember very well from last
night's rehearsal it is in fact a dicot
that is not on there we go you've got it
there well done that one has got a
particularly impressive unicorn that is
of course a duiker you and I think we
think that that Unicorn is there as a
sort of deterrent it's just hair
I had a unicorn when I was at school
David he had a piece of hair wouldn't
sit down
he's very embarrassing to plaque I
hadn't brushed my head no I wasn't brave
enough for a mohawk David
right it's continued along here Sharla's
powerful voices coming into the airway
so rusty and Herbie were tracking
Columba over there what he and the
trucks came into that area over there
which looks like very good leopard
country indeed and so Herbert Oh is very
kindly offered to help us try and find
her this afternoon and we will do our
best to give him a hand which will
probably mean we'll just drive around
aimlessly until he finds something for
us that's not true I was having a talk
with Jaime today and she said she said
to me this is something I must confess
there very few things I realized before
Jaime Patterson but this thing I
definitely did realize before her and we
were talking about the fact that many
people say that they are tracking a
leopard I'm going to go and track a
leopard well what they actually mean is
I'm going to go and find a leopard track
and then I'm going to blunder about in
the general vicinity of where that track
was made and if I find the leopard I
will say that I've tracked it but in
actual fact what will have occurred is
that it stepped out in front of me or
I've managed to spot at all I nearly
rode over it or I kicked it out of a
bush basically because it is so hard
unless you have the skills of Herbert
skills born of not a three-month
training course or a year-long training
course but of years and years and years
of refining the craft
all right let's go across to Jamie now
she broke her ariel as she drove out of
camp and I think Marcel is now fixed it
it is fixed it is fixed many thanks to
Marcel a very good afternoon to all
welcome to my portion of the sunset
Safari my name is Jamie and this
afternoon
Craig is behind the camera and we got
off to a truly auspicious start we were
probably about 50 meters outside of the
camp I went over a bump and the antenna
went look it's actually quite funny it
just kind of broke I guess it was it was
probably more entertaining if you were
there when one of those had to be there
moments but I thought it was hilarious
anyway it's it's wear and tear through
years of driving over bumps or however
long the antenna has been up there and
the plastic broke but naturally because
I was driving you can imagine the jokes
are going to flow for days to come until
people forget about it Oh jeepers
squirrel that made it back in the grass
yeah I would please don't add to the
stress of my afternoon just bounced out
almost under my tire there my word the
environment is not being kind to my my
poor adrenal glands now once upon a time
a broken antenna before a TV show would
have driven me mad with sheer stress but
now it was just funny no I just laughed
at it yes apparently James did let the
cats out of the bag obviously poor old
Lauren has had to sit much longer than
intended to babysit in Ghana for which I
am deeply deeply thankful we're making
our way there now I'm still
ages away and just let's just left camp
now I'll get there eventually I'm not
too worried he'll start moving in the
next half an hour or so I am worried
that he's just going to go bye-bye into
buffers hook in time for the TV show but
at least you guys will get to see him
before he does that that's my standard
TV luck Lions gone leopard god
so you know but and also of course a big
thank you to Sydney who is the one who
ultimately found him this sort of in the
middle of the day today we had relayed
we had relay teams so I went out this
morning where as soon as it got light
and then everybody jumped on board and
searched for animals from there and of
course as we finished morning Drive we
got the reports that the Lions had come
wandering across onto Juma speaking of
which off you pop across to Trish ala so
I can put my foot down and get and
relieve get to relieve Lauren now I've
got some really cute paws here don't you
think so I know it's not the word
usually associated with large male lions
but I do think that they're very very
cute now we've been joined by another
vehicle too so if you hear people
chattering in the background that's
probably what it is
it's definitely not emanating from the
Lions
he is stunning no he doesn't look as if
he's eaten too much you can see that it
slightly around in there but not quite
so I hope they'll get something Roberts
you'd like to know if there's another
male coalition that's a threat to the
Evoque as well the only one I could
think of for the Birmingham boys and
they have moved further south so I doubt
that they would actually come back this
way considering that they vacated the
area it's not as if they already as if
they're vulgar males had fought for this
territory they sort of just left it
vacant and the volca males came in so at
the moment I don't really think there is
going to be any issues or they are going
to be any issues for these males and
everything it seems to be going smoothly
so far not that I'm any doctor full-on
lion social kind of relationships but I
feel like the income is in them it's a
nice sort of stable lion family it would
be interesting to see what would happen
if other males come in about
I think it was about a month ago close
to the Manya letty boundary I had seen
another male that was actually not I
mean if he wanted to come in here he
could come in here apparently he had
wandered in from the Kruger probably a
nomadic male that's just kind of moving
about maybe trying to join the coalition
if it's slightly younger but it
definitely hasn't strolled down this way
and if it had it would mean quite
ferocious fights in fact fights to the
death if if he didn't retreat you'll
find that there you might may fight
amongst themselves as well between the
Evo cos as in within their coalition
they would fight especially when it
comes to around mating time or even
around a carcass they might but when I
say fight it's more of a scuffle they
hardly hurt each other unless there is a
major I suppose they have big
differences there is really no need to
fight because it doesn't benefit them to
be able to fight now I can hear lots of
you say the Avoca male is your spirit
animal right now I think so I think it
is brave and powerful and majestic is
that what you are clearly that is what
you are no I'm telling in this direction
because I can hear impalas just I can't
see them yet but in that direction I can
hear them and there were even some
behind us and they're very very noisy as
usual in the rutting season but I
thought that maybe it would get the
attention of these guys but clearly
they're too tired and it is too hot
although I didn't think it was that hot
today but maybe they just need a rest
they're not hungry just yet or they just
don't have the energy to do anything
about it just yet
look at that foot
I like that you say I couldn't get the
name there it was
Volvo Oh bold bold but you say that you
love seeing lions lying around oh I do
love it I love a cheesy joke I
absolutely do even better than a cheesy
joke as a cheesy joke with a bit of
science in it then I feel particularly
nerdy
very cute so after this I think I might
go out and see what the other one is
doing Robert you'd like to know when we
name when will we name these boys well
as far as I know when it comes to lions
or really most big high-profile animals
here we don't particularly we're not
particularly involved in naming them on
our own so it has a lot to do with the
other other lodges that are around and
all of that it's not as if they belong
to us that makes sense
so for me until the name comes along we
just kind of use descriptive names like
you would have heard mohawk pale blond
veil dark paint male so we use these
descriptive names it's really helpful
because it can we can tell who's who
just by the name it just helps with
memory as well but they'd have to be a
trio of some sort I think
it is a beautiful day in the African
bush look at that sunlight just creeping
through buds are going it is beautiful
all these horrible pests that sometimes
irritate them induce this little reflex
of the ears and the tail you'd have seen
that at the same way as you kind of
automatically SWAT when something lands
on you or scratch it's almost just an
automated response
I want to swing round because he looks
like he's fairly put and have a look at
the other evoke Emil but while I do that
let me send you over to James and see
how he's such is going
well it's not going too badly I was
feeling start insulted there I must tell
you insulted I was feeling because not
one of you has complimented me on my
haircut I don't know if I feel that
that's not really fair not even David
who's on camera even notice that had a
haircut I think is very unfair all right
I'll get over it eventually
and you won't see it but it's very bald
little bit of fuzz on top
oh yeah mr. Capote in the back did I
know oh yes I did they're just too bad
that's scar by the way if you're
interested yeah my grandmother's ashtray
youngster yeah thank you
this is world toaster sorry everybody
and get this on an ordinary game drive
all my follicles are dead David
Andrew you make a valid point you say
there's a difference between a shave and
a haircut yes yes I think that's fair
and my suppose I have had more of a
shave haven't I that's what I do with
the shaver right so we hadn't that
played from Herbie and Herbie has found
some old tracks those tracks are heading
towards the sort of area to the south of
quarantine hearings which are just south
of the camp just next to the camp so
possibly heading towards the waterhole
here by way of avoiding the hyena den
but possibly just hunting I think she's
just hunting and I think that if you
keep your eye on the dam cam that's
gonna be your best bet for trances of
Columba but we'll keep trying
so little giraffe calf tracks here
it's lovely afternoon apart from the
fact that I didn't shave very well
anyway we're also try and find some
other interesting creatures there's
something on the top of that termite
land I think it's another piece of
termite mound
yes look at that David gorgeous top of
the termite mound huh
Thank You mr. Nam Andrus you say the
bold and the beautiful huh am i the bold
and is David the beautiful I'm sure that
that's I'm happy about that
it was just a termite man that looked a
little bit like a leopard it is around
here I'm not sure any of you remember
I'm sure some of you remember that we
had Tandy and Colombo together and no we
didn't sorry we had only Tandy and Tandy
was looking for tell umber and she spent
about two hours I'm sort of calling and
calling around here and we thought
perhaps that something terrible had
happened but it was very characteristic
of Columba in her early years because or
her early months because she was
fiercely independent from almost the
word go all right let's go back to Jaime
Patterson she's made her way to the
northeast corner Bethel's hook with a
surprise
I have made my way to Prague but look
look look look what we've got here it
must be James's misty honey badger only
it's no longer misty how cool is this
sorry tink Arne is here but he is
currently settled down on the dam wall
and he's not moving so obviously we are
extremely excited about this honey
badger that is currently drinking from
one of the mud puddles well I think it's
drinking it could also of course be
digging for something as well possibly a
frog then get all sorts of things maybe
even catfish in the bottom of this dam
well but I think looking at its face now
and it pops back up I think it might be
water how cool is this this is the best
afternoon ever there's a leopard there's
a hippo sorry oh okay
Craig's having an issue with these
camera faith we need to actually just
try and sort that out quickly as ye as
quickly as possible this is a truly
auspicious afternoon it's bizarre I know
okay alright we'll be back shortly guys
we're gonna send you across to Trish
while we problem solve the Cameron we'll
be back hopefully well I have come to
the other mail now and we have Mohawk
mail here you can see he's really
obvious because he has kind of male
pattern baldness at the top just a
little bit but it's really obvious now
he tends to be a little bit skittish and
he was when I first entered here and
they were kind of split I thought let me
come to him first because he was not
asleep but as soon as he saw me moving
towards him he was just kind of very
skittish but then when we sit with him
for a few minutes he gets fine and he's
comfortable like he is now
it's always nice to have a lion that's
awake in the day she can see that he's
very sleepy you look very tired boy you
can see all those scratches on his face
which are sort of testament to I suppose
all he's experienced so pretty handsome
should I say I'm sorry I didn't mean to
call you pretty but I do think you're
pretty too very lazy lions as you can
see but I do hope that in the evening
they will start to be on the move
they'll probably be on the move slightly
earlier these days because the Sun is
setting earlier and the temperatures are
lower so who knows maybe they may just
go ahead and hunt we'll be lucky anyway
let's go to Jamie with that honey badger
that I'm so jealous about
we don't want to miss a moment of the
honey badger unfortunately it seems as
though Craig hasn't managed to sort out
his camera issues this is so exciting I
haven't seen a honey badger in forever
and I always enjoy them they're one of
my favorite animals just obviously I
think most people feel this way so what
we're gonna do is we're gonna bring in a
slightly wider audience just because
this is a so they're so exciting
welcome welcome to a truly unusual
sighting at this time of day a honey
badger digging through the dried and
cracked mud of a waterhole as we move
off into our dry season this of course
is 100 percent live and you're watching
us here in the greater Kruger National
Park area of South Africa so right up in
the top sort of northeastern corner of
one of the world's most beautiful
countries and biased of course and we've
got an animal that we hardly ever get to
see they're very very shy but of course
an animal that most people are familiar
with purely due to their fearsome
reputation so a honey badger of course
is known for its incredibly for tiny
little creature it's incredibly gutsy
behavior and the way in which it will
tackle predators much much larger than
itself Helen says that he is so cute he
is really cute
don't let oh look at him he's covered in
muddy water he's trotting away there's
some Franklin there and it's really
really unusual there are typically
nocturnal creatures or largely nocturnal
creatures you do occasionally see them
during the day but there times that you
actually get to see them are pretty rare
that was really very very cool and
there's actually quite a bit happening
there's a hippopotamus at the edge of
the waterhole as well hey Shelly our
honey badgers run off but you want to
know if he is fishing or if he was
fishing I think it's a possibility
Shelly he might have been digging for
water but I think he was looking for
frogs and fish in the dry der mud is a
much happening here at the moment he's
really really cool so I think he was
looking for something else I think he
was looking for food and I think that's
why that particular honey badgers been
hanging around this waterhole which of
course upsets the local inhabitants not
that he
a threat to the hippopotamus yes Susan
it is I'm pretty certain that it is the
same honey badger
that we saw the other day this he posed
a little bit upset it's not upset at us
though no you don't need to worry
there's so much going on at this
waterhole shame all of the animals get
increasingly stressed out as their water
dries up and it's obviously particularly
difficult for the hippopotamus of this
area we are going into the dry season
patty patty says that this is such a
beautiful sighting patty it really
really is it is a spectacular way to
spend a Sunday afternoon I really can't
think of a better way to do so he's
moving down into the water boy here you
go scattering his done with his tail I
remember that you can also ask your
questions as well in the comment section
now Chris you want to know if it's
normal for the hippos to be around an
area where there's no water at this time
of year Chris yes it is it really is
because there are certain areas where
the water holes have retained a little
bit of water but they are chock-a-block
full of hippopotamus at the moment and
for Bulls the male's like at this one it
becomes very difficult for them to
secure a spot in a place like that so as
a result males that aren't able to
compete with other males will actually
need to will actually need to move out
to other areas now I'm going to have to
do some shuffling around in a moment and
I'm probably going to have to move and
turn around
it's been amazing being joined by all
absolutely fantastic I hope you enjoyed
that honey badger sighting and I hope
that we get to see you again remember if
you want to see more of the Safari you
can google Safari live and you will find
us every day twice a day hope you had
fun and we'll see you on safari soon
all righty guys obviously Scuba Steve is
decidedly unsettled by all of the
activity that's going on in the water
around ting Ghana so ting Ghana's lying
on the dam wall you can't see him from
where I'm parked at the moment but there
are other vehicles here and that's
actually what core is causing Steve's
response and that's why I was sort of
getting a little bit nervy there at one
point because one of the vehicles is
trapped not trapped down there but one
of the vehicles is down there and it's
obviously he's now come down out of the
drainage line he wasn't in the water
when the vehicle made its way down there
but he's now popped out of the bushes
and he is discomforted hence why I was
trying to suggest we might need to
shuffle around so it's not us that he's
upset with but there's absolutely
nothing the guys can do except still sit
still for a little bit and hopefully not
add to any of his stress this is just
what happens with hippopotamus when they
are when they are in this kind of
position where there's no water around
so vehicles gonna try and move now while
he's where he is and going to try and
move out of the area that they're in
think they going to manage to get around
without getting too close to him that's
what they're gonna do they're gonna give
that a go
alright guys while we try and sort this
all out and I get you back into position
to seat in Ghana how cool is that we saw
a honey badger as well oh he gonna send
you across to Trish Allah who is still
with her lions how awesome honey badger
King Ghana and these two how awesome is
that that's actually very very very cool
it's gonna be a great Drive
this guy's still sussing us out just a
little bit he lifts his head up every
now and then to give me a look in fact
he gave me a yawn and a look of his lips
i fear i don't think you'll get too much
meat off me
and we're asleep but not quite no he
looks quite OSE like what an interesting
question you'd like to know if I know
whether nomadic males come from the
Kruger to mate I'm here I really
wouldn't know I mean a female and
Easter's is gonna mate with any males
that are around but the problem is you
don't want these males to find out
basically so the potential for it to
happen is obviously there but I don't
know if that is the purpose of them
moving out or just simply because
they're nomadic males they're constantly
moving but that's really interesting
it'd be nice to be able to actually
monitor a few males coming from there
and actually see what they do when they
get showed it just transitioned through
until they find a coalition or have they
just there's another really distinctive
features that kind of uneven but on his
by his bottom incisors he's got oh kind
of can you see it there we go he's
showing it to us there's a little kind
of kink yes thank you thank you you're
being very good and kind in showing it
to us but yes yes as we were saying
about the nomadic males yeah I'm really
not sure but the possibility is
definitely there as long as they don't
get caught I wouldn't want to be caught
with one of these peoples ladies look at
them they're going to smash anyone else
that comes in but of course only if they
know
since I've been here at least there
hasn't been any other males that have
come in I mean adult males of course we
had the monkey an email who came and the
TEL Amati male
oh Linda you say if we look closely at
his nose we will be able to say see the
letter A for Avoca well done mr. lion
you have labeled yourself very easily so
you can see now exactly why this is such
an easy one tidy because now that we
know he's got an A on his nose hopefully
he'll show it to us he's eyeing us out
properly and if the one is closed by the
eyes a little bit open
he seems Restless I wonder what it could
be she's not comfortable in your spot
every now and then I can hear him when
he kind of with his tongue in his mouth
hopefully he'll do a do one slightly
louder just now so you guys can hear -
oh he looks adorable slightly curled up
there
Susan you'd like to know if the Evoque
is ever venture into the Kruger
well the Kruger is actually not that far
from us the boundary for the crew that's
just kind of beyond before hook and my
near lady I think and as far as I know
these guys actually came from the timber
party so I'm not sure that they had
needed to cross into the Kruger or
whether they eventually there because
they they can but considering like I had
said that there were other males around
in that area who had already come in or
come out of the Kruger towards the side
even though not very closely I think
that would deter these guys from being
on the property at the same time I'll
bring in that area at the same time as
there's other males you see even though
animals do fight and they do defend
territories quite fiercely they don't
want to be injured because if they
injured it means that their fitness goes
down and they don't want their fitness
to go down because that means that their
survival or chance of survival is going
to be lower so that's not something that
any animal once so they will really only
fight if it's necessary for them to
fight or they find that the outcome of
the fight is more beneficial than the
detriment of having that injury so it's
kind of to find them the kind of balance
so um a lion or a leopard when the other
kind of predator would rather avoid
confrontation then actually actively go
out and seek it he's just finally turned
in I think as soon as I turn to the
camera he ID me out again oh he reminds
me of a housecat when he sits like that
all curled up in a little bundle very
sweet
in the tail you'll find that cats in
general have a very interesting kind of
lineage and though they have are
distantly distantly related to our house
cats and our smaller cats the big cattle
in lineage is a sort of a bit of a
mystery but anyway we'll talk about it a
little more in a bit let's go and see
how James search for la Londe is going
narcs well is the answer to that
questions not well at all
Roberto has continued to find more
tracks but if he says that she's hunting
and that means she's going up and down
or in local parlance if a tracker is
talking to his ranger who doesn't speak
correct Cheong gun he'd say mean corns
or leanza law up and down and that's
what is going on so they're going up and
down because she's hunting looking
around the place turning around walking
back the way having a second thought
hearing him parlor their bird call there
and so it's not easy to follow exactly
where she's gone never mind though I
know that audible fair concern for my
efforts but I shall prevail I believe so
today and David's efforts of course when
he is not feeding his face with biltong
biltong a south african delicacy and the
wise known as survival rations in the
west of the world and as jerky we've
been through the many times I think
we've been through South African cuisine
well unfortunately because I don't have
any animals I'm going to be kept to a
minimum length of segment so we're going
to get back to the leopard because
that's actually something we're looking
at
I'm sorry James but we already just
managed to get a good view of him so I'm
gonna cut you off I promise you you'll
find an animal Herbie we'll find Claire
lumber for you or something I don't know
as well as James's choice though he did
send me here and he did same Trish to
the Lions and I think that's just
because that's the sort of person that
he is mm-hmm so there's tin god I
promise you up but up until James linked
we had a really lovely view of his face
now we do not but never fear Scuba Steve
has calmed down he's back in his water
the vehicle is safe all is well I will
be able to shift around mm-hmm oh there
an elephant coming there's an elephant
coming is that the Limpy one he's
looking so much better that is really
really good news oh my word
you see this is why non-intervention is
the policy taken by the the various
people in this area man word
everything's coming to office up damn
this is epic a little boy he's looking
okay guys he really is he's definitely
walking better than when I last saw him
coming for a drink saw he's limping
badly I don't know exactly what's wrong
with him let's see if we can figure out
which limit is I haven't managed to do
that yet hey my boy hello you so he's
walked all the way from where James saw
him yesterday
Tibbles hook down I think he's gonna be
okay
left front no right front sorry
although left front looks a bit wobbly
as well
ben says that he is so happy to see that
he is doing so much better I know me too
I'm really relieved you know it's always
a difficult thing although he's going to
now have to try and get around Scuba
Steve I don't think Steve's gonna let
him drink
I really don't they were already he's
starting just snorted him off shame and
he's he's smaller than Scuba Steve he's
going to be intimidated come on Steve he
just wants a little bit of water having
such a rough time of things here you go
little one here we go but older than I
thought he was which is also good news
it could mean that he is a lot less
stressed about being separate from the
rest of his herd and you start to
develop a certain sense of independence
at around about this age it's definitely
is a car swollen I think that right
front wrist is the wrist joint decidedly
uncomfortable that's where the injury is
well now he's lifting up his back leg as
well I don't know what's going on here
to be honest I'm not a hundred percent
sure cuz no way the way is holding that
back leg is also I mean elephants to
reach their weight on their hips but
giraffe Bell wants to know if it could
possibly be from a snake bite giraffe
girl it's possible but highly unlikely
typically because snakes tend to avoid
trying to buy two elephants because
their skin is so thick it ends up
causing the snake more injury oh boy
come on Steve just hit him have a drink
just a little bit oh he's so much
smaller than Steve I don't know if he's
gonna be brave enough but he's walking
really really well compared to a few
days ago when I saw him when I saw him a
few days ago he barely moved come on
another one I think Steve's gonna let
him near the water's edge oh by the way
I did update I do keep providing updates
to those concerned when with regard to
this little boy so the management of the
reserve is aware of him and they're
monitoring his condition to see how he's
faring at the moment there's no they did
go and check him and there's no
indication that this injury was man-made
it looks like a natural injury oh boy
get your drink there's big mean come on
you can do it
Chris says it looks like his right rear
leg is swollen as well I mean the wrist
of the right front is definitely swollen
but you right I mean that the back leg
the left back looks much thinner and
smaller than the right maybe he fell on
his right side and that's what that's
why I've been struggling to tie down
exactly where the injury is looks like
he's gonna get to the water without
being chased by Steve he's refused to be
intimidated good boy here we go oh yeah
not didn't like that very much both
better cleaner water their elephants are
notoriously picky well done having a
drink at the separate side of the dam
too Steve
he is looking a little bit thin
so apparently lots of you wondering if a
car could do that to an elephant
oh sorry hold on one second
yeah um guys I've been trying to fill up
I'd like to make my way in
he is fun oh sorry I was answering a
question about the car it's it's
possible but it is highly highly highly
unlikely I think that is people looking
for a reason to help to treat him rather
than it actually being a factual thing I
think this most likely explanation is he
got shoved over by a big elephant and he
went over on the wrist joint and
possibly the ankle joint as well
he is looking very sore but it has
massively improved and you know it comes
down to the conversation we saw often
have and people are allowed to disagree
but ultimately it's never our decision
ultimately it is the decision of and
it's the approach of most of South
Africa that's in big open systems where
nature can manage herself she is allowed
to do so and a far more likely
explanation look if he'd been obvious
evidence of a bullet wound or a snare
around those limbs then he absolutely
would be treated but also bear in mind
that if it is a fracture or a break
there is actually nothing anyone can do
are you chiming in ting Garner yes no
any more you've got to say no you just
gave us a little sore there hmm so the
the non-intervention issue ultimately is
a decision made by people who've been
doing this for a very long time and it's
not made without compassion it really
isn't
but a fractured bone there's nothing
that can be done
he is them but I think he is recovering
to be honest I've never seen him move
like this before I think it might be a
sprain Michael wants to know whether or
not this really could get sick from
drinking this water first of all Michael
welcome it's lovely to have you on board
it's not a name that I've heard before
secondly no the digestive systems of
these animals and their immune systems
are such that it takes a lot to actually
upset them and to make them ill so no he
won't be made ill by that he is
absolutely fine look elephants of picky
if they have the choice they will oh boy
they will definitely drink fresher water
they often dig water as well but it will
not make him ill you'll see as you
continue to watch these live safaris
we've seen all sorts of creatures eat as
well the most unimaginable things green
carcasses with maggots dripping off them
sorry I don't mean to put you off
watching I realized as I said that that
sounded quite revolting that my
intention was not to chase you away but
no he won't get sick from drinking this
water he will however be no water in
about a month's time and then it becomes
more difficult he's going to have to
recover soon so that he can start
covering larger distances to get to
other water
definitely definitely walking better Oh
not speaks not where is this leopard
gone I've lost the leopard hang on
I think he's snorting at the leopard
where's the liquid gone
pretty interestingly enough he pretty
wants to know if it could be some kind
of arthritis look he is a he's a young
elephant and the only and I only know
this from working it's far alive
actually the only times that you find
elephants with arthritis is when they
are have been living in captivity there
is something Oh popcorn
leopard urine popcorn scent the only
time that you find in Athens get
arthritis as if they had been living in
a circus or a zoo and they haven't moved
about enough where is he gone Craig I
can't see him they're all looking this
way though so he must be just below me
mm-hmm
is he walking oh yes there is which way
should we look
elephant okay guys there's a good chance
my signal is about to disappear I'm
gonna give you a brief look at him
quickly because we can't see him now and
then I'm going to have to loop up and
around to get to where he's moving to so
while I do that
off you pop across a two trehala who is
still with the Avoca males oh I really
hope your signal doesn't disappear Jamie
the last thing we want in gremlins today
I really hope that they don't interfere
we need to all pull some money and send
them on vacation to the North Pole
preferably now this guy's only moved
around a little bit but let's go of
course what I expect they still seems a
bit Restless it's not a hundred percent
asleep he does get up every now and then
give us a bit of a yawn stretch and then
he's flopped over on to the other side
again now we were talking about how the
big cat adds his ancestry is a bit of a
mystery or sort of nobody has been able
to find too much fossil evidence for
them
in fact the
fossil that is currently be found or the
most the fossil that most closely
resembles modern-day lions it's wrong
about two million years ago when
Tanzania which is very recent in the
whole cat lineage to be honest because
the cat family that is normal small cats
plus the big cats and all of that they
have a history of about 40 million years
or at least their ancestors branched out
at that point but these big big cats
they have sort of a gap so we don't
really know what the kind of missing
link between the small cats and the big
cats is there was also a fossil found
that was three-and-a-half million years
ago also in Tanzania and those ones are
the ones that I'm saying resemble this
cat particularly or resembles big cats
particularly so they are a bit of a
mystery
but some recent work has actually
pointed to an extinct animal now called
Panthera blight ta which was found
probably about four point one to five
point nine million years ago so it adds
a little bit more to their to their
lineage a few extra years to the lineage
Nora you would like to know if I ever
feel odd or if there's ever time when I
make eye contact or feel the need to
break eye contact in fact just when I
got here he stared at me so intently
that I felt the need to break my eye
contact and that's happened before not
really with well it has happened with
your vocals as well but not intense like
this was because he's eyes were bright
orange and had the Sun coming in on it
and he was staring at me but the last
time that had happened was with ten
Ghana and he stared at me quite
intensely and I had to actually avert my
eyes
it's a creepy thing it's almost as if
you feel safer if you don't look it's a
weird way but in the same way when you
look at them then you have this kind of
connection it's a weird thing but I love
it makes you feel alive as you'll see
when he does tend to look at us he's got
quite an intense stare even when I've
taken photographs of them he
particularly has a very intense gaze
into your soul almost
he has just lifted his back leg for what
appears to be nothing because it only
picked up about 10 centimeters off the
ground and then he promptly put it back
down are you dreaming no you're not
quite asleep
Puma you'd like to know if I know where
Lions evolved well interestingly we've
always kind of assumed that they and
they evolved in Africa and that would be
a pretty safe assumption considering how
well adapted they are and how they've
kind of taken over in terms of being the
top predator one off the top predators
but the recent work I was telling you
about where in the Himalayas they found
this Panthera blight da is actually
pointing to central central northern
asia as being where they had originated
so it's quite different to what we first
expected but in that area apparently
their lineage or at least we have
evidence for their lineage at about ten
point seven million years so it's quite
interesting to see how they have
primarily kind of stuck around in Africa
or they have been very very successful
in Africa I always find it very
interesting to think about how these
animals came about and why they are the
way they are and so much of it has to do
with the ecology it's not just the
animal it's about the environment and
all of that as well anyway I did tell
him at the top of the hour I will be
going into his brother and going to go
visit him so this is the top of the
hours let me move on and go to the other
vole kamil and check on him in the
meantime let's go over to James and see
how his search is doing
we have got some starlings which I know
are not quite as exciting as lions but
you know we are doing our best I promise
to find you some cats there are two
different species of starlings no less
we have got the Cape glossy Starling the
one with the yellowish shine and in came
a virtual Starling as well the one with
the black eye I actually stopped here
because there was a squirrel sitting
very nasty sort of bathing in the Sun
and then David threw himself around on
the back of the car and the squirrel ran
away and so now we are substituting the
squirrel for the starlings also quite a
nice picture up top there David yeah but
you might not like it's got pretty
colors but there's a an Impala sitting
there it's quite nice I like it too am i
taking the legal photograph of it
lightest superb on it
even site thinks it's very beautiful
that's cool
Thank You faith we do what we can you
know for the cause
one of them's going the other
Tim that's a very interesting question
and the answer is very seldom do male
impalas kill each other during the rut
they break their horns I've seen a
couple of eyes that have been stabbed
out which is quite unpleasant but I have
I don't actually think I've ever seen an
Impala that's been killed by another
Impala during the rut and if you see
them having their fights that's quite
surprising they do have some fairly
vicious contract or confrontations and
yeah and I'm sure they get nasty
headaches but they don't seem to
actually ever kill each other which is
very interesting
could you probably kill each other more
when they get their horns locked up they
get killed quite a lot water buck
apparently are responsible for the most
antelope deaths sailfin for conspecific
and caused deaths I've tried to say that
in a fancy way and failed horribly
basically what about kill each other
more than any other kind of antelope
does but yeah I mean despite the fact
that these guys seem to be much more
violent and they don't tend to wipe each
other out nearly the frequency that
water buck do I wish this bunch would
try and find me a little looking sort of
in our direction
Oh little swifter hundreds and hundreds
of greater blue yet glossy starlings and
juma and in fact the one with the yellow
eye that we saw earlier could have been
great to bleed glossy Starling I didn't
hear a call and if you don't hear that
it call it's very easy to confuse them
with a cape Lagasse Starling and in the
light that we had I could easily have
been a greater blue eared glossy
Starling we get both of them in
abundance around here so absolutely
you're obviously a bit of a birder and
for sure we get them they make the
easiest way to distinguish their calls
well I find that the easiest way I've
actually never met anybody else who
knows what the hell I'm talking about
but I'm gonna try and tell you the
greater blue eared glossy Starling has
got a sort of swizzle 'uncle if you like
and the no doesn't the Cape glossies got
a bubbling call and the great abbreviate
glossy Starling has got a kind of whiny
call again so I like to think of it
saying oh well the Cape gloss is
darlings gentle bubbling cool sounds
like darling darling
so now I'm sure you'll all definitely be
able to identify the difference not so
everyone good nice picture there David
David's taking a nice picture don't you
think everybody that's an aging actually
my taking legal one myself
- obviously not nearly as pretty as
David's that's cause David is a
professional
there's a very gorgeous picture indeed
all of your green that's David
despite his general repulsor trances
managing to produce a gorgeous picture
now of course the Sun Goes Down the
tracking becomes that much harder called
Herbert I will have to go home very soon
we will keep trying
all right mashaallah is on shift with
the two Avoca males she's moved from
Hana to the other
I have and I did warn the no hawked mail
that I will be moving on soon and it
will now be his brothers show no now the
vehicle has joined us again if you can
hear the engine in the background
everyone wants to get their eyeful of
these guys now like I was saying before
I really hope that they'll get up a
little bit earlier on the hunt because
of course of the temperature and the
length of the days now the darkness
that's coming in slightly earlier so
cute I hope they both are not offended
by me using cute to describe them but I
do think that they are now talking about
hunting and them being waiting for it to
cool down before they actually get on
the hunt it's actually quite relevant
for something else and that is climate
change and the rising daytime
temperatures now we may not think that
it could affect predators in this kind
of way but we know that Predators don't
do well in the heat and we know that
they can overeat overheat easily and if
it is hotter in the days in during the
day then the time that they can actually
invest in possibly what they would have
hunted even if it was towards the end of
the day or just when the Sun is I'll be
affected maybe even those times when
they may be active are no longer good
enough for them because it's too hot so
that's actually an implication of global
warming that we don't often think of and
especially for wild dogs this can be
very true because they will hunt in the
day and when they do that that time that
they can
in hunting is really really shortened
not only is it shortened the intensity
of the heat while they are on the hunt
for those few parts of the day when it
is cool enough it's still going to be
higher than they would normally be
exposed to so there's also those type of
things to think about and especially
when it comes to male lions and of
course the mane and the testosterone
that evolved in the growth of the mane
has a lot to do or apparently has a lot
to do with temperature and climate so if
the lion was in an area where it was
particularly hot then that can actually
influence how and it grows its vein or
the darkness which it grows its Mane and
the length to which it's grown it grows
its Mane but apparently the length at
which or how long the mane is only
really matters between males sizing
themselves up and doesn't actually
matter to the females and that the color
is what matters to the females we're
talking about temperature let's actually
have a look at his mane even though it's
we can't see it too well but it's nice
and thick where's the other males mane
is slightly less thick and apparently in
the heat this Mane is very uncomfortable
and you would think so I would think so
it got this horrible really big scarf
around your neck constantly but that
means that females think you can deal
better with the climate than the other
males do so all these little pieces of
the puzzle kind of fitting in the
evolutionary puzzle anyway hopefully he
will get up in a little bit in the
meantime let me send you over to Jamie
with her cat hopefully doing something
of course 10 Ghana doesn't have a main
but he is still intimidating in his own
right he has a Judah instead which is a
massive sort of pouch of skin that
extends from his jaw right down to his
chest right now he's fixated on
something in the bush I think he spotted
some impala and he is definitely in need
of a nice meal he's not at the chub
eating ghana that we are so accustomed
to seeing his ever-present limp is there
it was worse when he got up earlier it's
now sort of stretched out and warmed up
but life is about to get quite difficult
for us because he is definitely
interested in something in this in this
vegetation his ears of course far more
powerful when ours
he's obviously picked up the sound of
movement it doesn't necessarily have to
be Impala no in quiet there just to
listen because I thought I heard him
part of rutting but I think it is a sign
of his age that he is looking so thin
during rutting season because it really
is it becomes so much easier for the
Predators to catch themselves male
Impala that you don't generally see if
and looking leopards at this time of
year maybe he's just had a run of bad
luck I suppose and he has been absent
enough that I thought he was on a kill
ok mr. Ketchum I'll catch him obviously
fraud you viewers I'm not going to go
and grab him this is good
South South is good we like south south
is away from Buffalo where are you going
onto that termite mound
no we're changing direction we are
sitting on a termite money I just want
to see where I'm trying to see what he's
seen no Kathy wants to know if Tenggara
would ever attempt to go after the
injured elephants I'm sorry guys there's
another vehicle care cool all right
stand by sorry Greg viola chuffing
around there mmm we obviously can't put
people on camera so if we can avoid it
so I've gotta just reposition hmm no
that that elephant is to Big Foot in
Ghana there's no way if that elephant
died naturally yes you would eat eat it
hello my boy I'm sorry I'm enough to
sneak quite close to you but I don't see
your your hunting target yet so I think
you'll be okay with that minister
it's about as good as I can do for now I
wonder if he's found a Waterboro that's
what he's heard something in these holes
that would be exciting for tonight
so while I speculated poor James has
been doing a lot of speculating it
hasn't necessarily worked out in his
favor yet what we have got here however
is a hyena and it's written as far as I
can tell and I'm going to follow her
because I think she might be as
effective as tracker as any out here I
believe the den was active a little bit
earlier and therefore I'm sure she's
just lifted and it's possibly leading us
to where she can smell some meat so I
think now interestingly when you do
follow our hyena off-road you've got to
keep your distance because they don't
tolerate it quite as well as lions and
leopards do but they also tend to walk
in straight a dour directions so you can
give them a little bit more space she is
and often along well-worn paths
so let's see where she takes us I'm done
if any of you managed to get a good
enough view there to decide if that was
ribbon but I'm pretty sure it was from
the ear that looks like a bee not a
buzzy bee a bee litter be little bit and
also she could just be heading to the
damn can for a bit of a drink she's
turning cuz I don't think you're high
you know whatever intentionally lead us
in a the wrong direction
no she felt threatened enough and we
were near a din and she thought we were
after her maybe she might she definitely
smelling something look at her
see oh here we go here we go
he's picked something up on the wind
hold on tight everybody David where'd
she go she goes - right there
you got her have you one o'clock
going at high speed though this is a
nasty patch of ground with some dirty
stumps just smelling it is fantastic now
that's the block that Herbert's in
tracking I don't think he is in any
danger whatsoever from her but I think
that her intentions are precisely the
same as his not amazing turn our head to
the little breezy
it's gonna let her try and get a
direction
okaythat's carry on she's running now
Oh going straight into the block
everybody is gonna get a bit rough
running off here oh yeah you see her
there Dave she went up the rewards the
lift
zeki where that was going alrighty we're
gonna hand you back over to Jamie while
we try and figure out what's going on
here very exciting stuff alright so
while James unravels that puzzle all
that ribbon huh we are trying to unravel
a mystery of our own has ting gone has
seen something in the distance or is he
deliberately open he has going to wait
it out on this termite mound this
termite mound is active it is an active
burrow all the grass seeds in the eyes
hey my boy mark his territory Oh his
face looks a lot thinner you know that I
gotcha vide
I gotcha vide somebody said shoot to me
when they moved in to see the lip that
was quite appalled
I had no ego no you can see him here he
goes
he's definitely either seen or heard
something off in the distance oh it's
going to be tricky now as he moves
through this area I don't like this
block but oh well now Lauren you want to
know if the female leopards will find
the large juleps attractive no not
necessarily but biological selection
will favor males with a large julep
because it means they can get an ideal
territory that a I'm just going to make
sure I don't lose him just bear with me
Oh spiderweb Craig I'll save you I
didn't save you I'm sorry I did my best
so they'll obviously be able to compete
generally a bigger julep means a bigger
size leopard competes for better
territory meaning that no problem
meaning that they therefore are
potentially attractive to females in
this area but to be honest females are
attracted to a male and are there is
there's a hole there that's what he's
after
let's go have a look hmm
Sophie sorry I'm really struggling to
concentrate on everything happening hmm
so a female leopard will mate with any
possible partner because that will
ensure her safety of her cubs okay while
I get into position here let's go across
to James who by the sound of the game
Drive radio has found something
potentially interesting something to the
block
not everybody we found what she's got
she's got a rotting occupied she's found
a rotting porcupine every said this is
exactly way he had the fresh track but
this animal is rotten you can smell it
you can't obviously you got lucky you
can't unbelievable look at that
I'm short telomer would have tried to
feed on it even if she wasn't if it
wasn't her that killed the porcupine is
the first porcupine I've seen here and
Juma this is ribbon now ribbon is not a
high-ranking member of the Juma clan and
so let us see if the theory plays out
that the lower anchors will not take
food back towards the den and indeed
she's not heading anywhere near the den
is to also keep a high lookout for the
possibility of Columba being right
around here ya know how you know if you
managed to eat that thing I tell you
what you've got a stomach a second to
none because the odor coming off it is
profound
where is she taking it there
and noses are so amazing it is amazing
isn't it is underneath
but that thing's been dead at least two
days really doesn't if something cruel
where she's trying to take it I'm just
gonna try and keep my distance a bit
there so I know this might not be the
best picture but she seems a little bit
like she's trying to get it away from us
oh yes Tim the cools can still hurt her
for sure
the only difference is of course that
they are not attached to them well they
are attached but they're not attached to
working muscles which means that the
porcupine cannot sort of face them and
make them stiff and point them at the
hyena and she's also can't back into the
heiner she's having a full ger now
oh my goodness is now scratching herself
on the quills or possibly trying to pick
up the smell of the rotting carcass
goddamn my dinner tonight David I'm
going to try and get us a little bit
closer so we can at least like a bit of
you Oh
would Tenggara scavengers meal from
ribbon he might he might it's a female
hyena a small female hyena probably a
slightly lighter than ting garner not
much though and not a dominant hyena so
you might try as luck she's covering
herself now in the stink of this thing
was that right let's just keep an eye
out because there'll be a little Lepidus
somewhere around here
absolutely astounding
I mean I'm assuming that's the
porcupines bladder not her own
it's a little bit like getting some ice
cream David and then pushing your face
into it
you can't leave it there you're just
going to leave it general you're a new
viewer and you say I'm I'm scared being
first to her like this no not Janet
Janet the reason is that she's used to
our vehicles she's used to us and she
doesn't see us all the vehicles as a
threat and most importantly she doesn't
see us as something to eat and no
apparently does she see that porcupine
there's something to eat I'm going to
leave the carcass there because I want
to follow this hyena I think she may
well lead us to our ultimate goal which
is Shalem alphas what Andy fascinating
was that incredible like I said I wonder
if Columba didn't kill that porcupine
and then reject it because it was too
difficult to eat and then it's been
rotting for two days at least
and dark now see if she goes back
towards the den the den is down off to
my left hand side there
she's not going towards there she's
going back sort of towards where she
found the target I can smell it in fact
we're driving exactly on our own tracks
here drink that's quite anise all right
the Sun has gone it's getting dark and
I'm sure their voters are going to get
up soon I'm sure they will and I really
hope that they do and I have a feeling
they will because I think they're hungry
I do their stomachs are not particularly
large the definitely don't look
unhealthy they both look in great
condition you can see the lights cut in
a bit pink which is because of course
the Setting Sun has cast them in it's
lovely light very very pretty now we
were talking about mains and we spoke
about the testosterone influence on the
Mane's of the of the males now typically
only males have Mane's but they have
been a few incidences of females having
Mane's as well I can recall one in
Botswana a few females in Botswana
possibly that grew Mane's and started
actually to behave a bit like male lions
and they would send Park often and Korb
often or more often than females
normally do because males will call and
send mouths more often than the females
do and it's time to behave in that way
so that sort of tells us that there must
be quite a direct link between having
the main and the amount of testosterone
in the animal in fact there was another
example it was in South Africa but I
can't recall where exactly and there was
a female that had a Mane as well and it
was found that she actually had an issue
with her ovaries and she was producing
more testosterone and after she had
sorted that out or the vet had sorted
that out
she returned to normal iron s behavior
calling list and scent marking less so
there kind of gives us the direct link
between testosterone and the mane but of
course there might be a lot more other
genes and chemicals that are influencing
it but for short testosterone does play
a key role this is what I'm waiting for
I'm waiting for the very slow waking up
that the Lions do before they get up for
the night tweet-tweet you are a new
viewer welcome aboard so glad to have
you with us you would like to know if
the Voges would form a new pride well
there's a few things to talk about there
firstly males like the Evo cos they form
coalition's so when males are about
three years old they're kind of pushed
out of their pride by the adult males
and then they form a coalition in the
years to come sometimes I can take them
a bit of time but eventually most of
them do although you do get some nomadic
males and if pride is the group of
females and their offspring and a pride
would sort of belong to a coalition so
the vocals won't make or create their
own pride or try to join their own pride
they are already part of a group of
family of lions that we have here
and they form a coalition that is males
that are working together and of course
the females the pride they always come
together and they'll see each other very
often but the males will leave for a
long time sometimes weeks and that I
haven't seen them with the Incans but in
canoes also move around quite a bit and
sometimes a male coalition of the
territory that a male coalition occupies
can overlap quite a few prides so that a
few prides can belong to a lion and that
is of course an area where the lions are
ready at a high density but in an area
like this from what I know
the Voges are linked only at the moment
to our coalition think of Hummers and I
think this Torchwood pride but I am not
sure about the sticks so in fact if you
guys know you can actually let me know
because I do know the Torchwood pride
and the Inca Houma pride do belong to
them by thinking am i leaving anybody
out lmarti pride as well
they're impalas rutting all around us
and add to the noise that I'm hearing so
that's why I'm hoping that these guys
will get up and start to pick off what
is really easy prey for the moment
considering that the condition will be
kind of low the impalas that is that I'm
talking about
so we tweet back to your question the
the Inca the Evo cos will not form their
own pride Rob you'd like to know if I
know where the third Avoca is I don't
know where the third Avoca is but in my
experience with them I have noticed that
when two of them are kind of down this
wire down the side the other one usually
hangs around a bit a bit more to the
north now that's just something I've
observed I don't know if that's where he
is right now
but in my past experience that is what
I've seen
now I said I was waiting for this I was
waiting for the snow awakening of the
lines which is what happens around this
time when the Sun is setting and it
starts with a few movements some
stretching some yawning then there's of
course the defecating that goes on they
relieve themselves and then they are on
the move
so this is a good sign that he's turned
over goat face he would like to know how
old the Evoque Emile's asked while they
were born in 2013 so I don't know
exactly which month that they were born
it's a sort of hard especially if you
haven't followed them from Cubs but I'm
sure someone out there knows exactly
which month they were born in but 2013
is the year so either they're coming on
six or they are already six years old
do you have an interesting question
you'd like to know if it's always the
same one that's missing or do they kind
of rotate well it's not always the same
one that's missing because I have seen
them all so I suppose they do sort of
rotate but also they're not constantly
sticking by each other's side within a
few meters you know they can always go
off in their own and explore a bit and
then come back or regroup but I have
seen them all in fact I've seen them all
in on one day as well on Juma so they
must rotate in a way or I guess it's
also a bit of chance this one feels like
coming this way oh are you dreaming
there was a small jaw shudder there
right now it's moving even in the
slightest and just the fact that he's
moving is making me slightly happy so
let's see what they made get up - once
the Sun is completely down in the
meantime let me send you over to James
and see how he's such is going for
chilapa real stuck
it's tremendously exciting hold on David
you're holding on everybody only on
today Z's okay uh hyena is now along
this game path on which our leopards
have often traveled we've just passed
her B's on his way home and he says he's
convinced this leopard is still around
this area he's had tracks going up and
down from this morning and from this
afternoon and he's convinced that they
stole something from her but that she's
still in the area
and I think that this hyena is also
convinced to the same thing so we are
going to do our level best to follow her
and you see her anymore David not at the
moment
now thank you
what
this is not an easy place to be driving
in fact it's eseni impossible now you're
going to have to go back out onto the
road and see if we can make our way
around where this a game park terminates
Susan I think there are two reasons
she'd have abandoned that carcass and
not carried it to the den the first
reason is that she's a low-ranking hyena
and therefore rather than take meat back
to the den often low ranking hyenas will
eat away this years they'll eat away
from the den and then sort of convert
their energy if you like into milk and
take the milk back for their cubs
because only their own Cubs will suckle
from them the other reason is I think
that it was obviously just distasteful
it was very rotten that's not normally
much Oh jeepers that's not normally much
of a deterrent but I don't know why
necessarily she thought that one was
particularly more distasteful than any
other perhaps it was the quills and she
realized that it was just going to be
too difficult and not worth her while to
pick a clean before she ate it and I
suspect that was probably had something
to do with that she was going along this
little game path here this is really
there she is there you can just see her
disappearing and testing okay let's
continue I do think we should keep
following her though I think it's gonna
be worth our while
and she's been relatively confiding as
well for a hyena I say they don't often
let us follow Olympics or Road David you
still there
hmm times like these that I wish I was
driving a bulldozer alright let's get
back to Tricia I think and see if we
can't find this in some privacy and you
can maybe find focus calling nice well a
my line has gotten up so I'm so glad
about that it's only a matter of time so
we are ready I've got my jacket on and
we are ready to keep up with him what
are you gonna do this is always a really
nice time of the night because what
happens you slowly get this build-up and
sort of a suspense and where they're
gonna go and what are they gonna do
because when it comes to this time
that's when they want to be up and
they're hunting I didn't tell you there
are some Impala around he kind of just
now gave a see see that movement of the
head a kind of forward Oh big yawn
beautiful he was starting to want to
give a small raw earlier so I think he
will roll for us tonight
dangerously simple you'd like to know if
lions dream oh well one I wouldn't
really know but I can tell you about
what I think from what I've read because
it's hard to conclusively kind of know
if lions do or not if any animal really
does or not but dreaming is associated
with REM sleep rapid eye movement sleep
and it's the same with us when we are in
REM sleep that's when we dream so
whether the lion actually has REM sleep
which I think it would considering the
amount of time that it sleeps for then
there's nothing stopping it from being
able to dream so I would imagine that
they could I know for certain that
elephants do go through a period of REM
sleep hello you handsome boy so there's
no reason why they shouldn't be able to
dream look at those eyes do any of you
feel the need to avert your eyes but he
has quite a gentle stare
no he was sort of really softly trying
to call and I wonder if he was trying to
get the attention of his brother nearby
Jean you'd like to know if I'm not
scared that I'm sitting this close to
him and I think at first I probably was
but now that I'm used to them and I'm
used to their behavior and I've learned
a lot about their behavior it's a lot
better in fact that sort of fear factor
goes away
and that is testament to knowledge is
power because so many things were scared
of if only we actually took the time to
learn about them we'd realize that
they're actually not that scary
there are times like when the mohawked
male that's behind us stared at me I
think I said he has a very intense day
come on boy
he just gave us I to contact corner I
have a feeling he's going to try and get
together with his brother and then they
will move off together into the night
come on boy no he's decided not to
perform on cue just yet he's still
warming up but you will get there okay
I'm just gonna be quiet
boy one more
still going up but wasn't that amazing
that sound is unbelievable it kind of
sends a vibration through and when my
feet when my feet are actually on the
metal of the car at the bottom of the
pedals you can hear the vibration
[Music]
in fact I'm gonna one with tweeters you
guys need to tell me what your one would
is a snake Safari live because that was
epic and if you were listening closely
you would have heard this and have a
lion responding really really softly in
the background all that was exciting
what are you gonna do I think my one
word would be all absolutely awestruck
like I was saying to you that is so loud
and you can feel the vibration it kind
of go from your feet that's touching the
metal up into your body
Kimberly your one word is magnificent
absolutely it's just magnificent at its
finest
I'm wondering who is going to come and
join him here because his brother isn't
here by
catch you'd like to know if the rowing
is a dominant thing or dominance thing
or is just a communication thing it
there are different types of rows you
will get a contact call which is kind of
sounds like a the beginning of a roll
mm-hmm like that
and then of course you'll get the
full-blown row now these often obviously
get used at different times and for
different things but a lot of the time
in general it's going to be a deterrent
to any other liens that are in the area
so suppose it can eat any role kind of
acts as a territorial marker anyway well
I'm going to stick around with him and
hopefully his brother will join him soon
maybe the third brother will - who knows
in the meantime let me send you over -
and the other two cats and that is Jaime
and ting gana okay well that was
probably one of the most stressful
periods in my week he took us all the
way into a round leafed tika thicket and
within round leafed
Atika thickets one often finds artifact
burrows which is of course what he
wanted but it was an absolute nightmare
and we lost him completely and if it
hadn't been for the other vehicle we
actually never would have found him well
we would have his calling so we would
have actually found him but sure that
was exhausting I thought I was so scared
that he was going to settle down outside
the entrance to one of those burrows
where I couldn't see him I mean that
thicket was impenetrable and that that
was where he was going to stay the whole
night that I am deeply relieved to tell
you that he's back out on the road and I
can only hope he decides to sit here for
the next however long it may be
I'm really sure how much longer we've
got left till the TV show I'm sure where
I am in space or time it's a mark of how
much work I did try to follow him and
Greg to that even though it's really
quite chilly now I am boiling I'm
absolutely boiling and the problem with
round leaf teak thickets as most of you
will know is that the elephant's
actually farm them so they keep them
there browse them down to a certain size
but a lot of the time there's hidden
stumps below these tiny scraggly looking
bushes that are as you would have
guessed with the name teak completely
solid they're just waiting to take out
of steering arm and that combined with
the paranoia of once again following
Tigana and falling into an artifact hole
was positively unmanageable I mean did
some very slow first gear driving anyway
the Juke failed in his efforts to find
himself an aardvark or a warthog which i
think is what he was after
no those of you wondering if I heard the
Evoque whose roaring I heard nothing
except the sound of my own heartbeat and
the odd crunch and crackle of leaves as
I attempted to move around yes and no I
haven't heard them we are on the
opposite side of Juma we're actually
about as far east as trishula is far
west if that makes any sense she's on
the west and there I can hear them
I think
there I could actually hear them but
we're on the eastern boundary morph
Eastern corner okay apparently trishaws
Lions aren't roaring so I'm hearing
something else
tweet-tweet welcome to our live safaris
tweet-tweet I don't know whether you're
tweeting or whether or not you are in
the comments section of the YouTube chat
but or whatever you call it
mmm you want to know if yep it's usually
hunt at night they do it really depends
upon the leopard itself so it's I was
just trying to make a tweeting joke I'm
sorry mmm it was lame the the lipids
I've seen leopards hunt during the day
I've seen leopards hunt at night they
probably do on the balance of things
they probably do the majority of their
hunting at night it's way they stealth
really comes into its own
and they're probably most successful at
night but I have seen leopards hunt and
all hours often in the middle of the day
I've seen this male leopard walk around
when it's 48 degrees centigrade outside
it really depends upon how hungry the
leopard is it's full moon at the moment
which also makes life a bit more
difficult for the Predators because it
means that the prey animals can see
slightly eats slightly easier slightly
more easily they can see more I can't
speak that does not bode well they can
see more the moon of course increases
the ambient light and even as a human
being you'll find that you it fades
laughing at me only 10 seconds delayed
because of our delay I'm trying I swear
it's also embarrassing because I'm right
parked right on top of another vehicle
just turn trish down Thank You Trish for
that update what's a light oh yes you'll
find even as a human if you move about
during full moon you can really see
Paula I know he does look so comfy
doesn't he I do hope he stays comfy in
fact if he could stay there for the next
mm-hmm
little while I would be profoundly
grateful he's got to stay 36 minutes in
the same place
okay faith is going with an hour so he
only gets up halfway through the TV show
I'm okay with that
I can do half an hour on a flat in Ghana
and then half an hour on a moving to in
Ghana I can handle that actually are
quite like that good idea faith because
if he gets moving in the next 36 minutes
there's a chance he'll be off the
property before the end of the TV show
we should have a betting pool going for
our TV shows don't you think not of
course that I'm encouraging gambling of
Okaz cross I would say 3 to 1 odds
Dingaan acrosses 5 to 1 odds James James
finds a number I'm not gonna say
anything
definitely not
ting connoisseurs very strong
possibilities about to do that now I'm
so good
those of you wondering about the light
coming on and off it is a another guest
vehicle who's with us in the citing
joint in Ghana nothing wrong with it at
all
mm-hmm it just has to do with oh here we
go
sit down it basically you know he's an
adult male lipid it doesn't bother his
eyes at all because of the way that
lipids no no no please no please no
please please not back in there not no
ting Ghana so it just reflects off the
membrane but we don't because we have
cameras that are able to see using
infrared light then we don't need to
worry about the spotlights but we do
still use them in situations like this
thank you thanks guys much appreciate it
thanks
I own up time for mourning he's going to
disappear so quickly okay bye-bye guys
you going off to Trish while I
concentrate for all the end of the
Safari I will catch you shortly yes you
need to concentrate Jaime it hopes that
she'll be able to keep up with ting
garner but this has been such an awesome
evening we've had so much vocalization
and this guy is just getting started
because he's still doing at the
beginning of his role every now and then
and I have a feeling he is going to sit
and wait until he's joined by the others
one of the others before he actually
gets often moves because I would have
actually thought that after he moves up
or gets up and starts moving around and
starts actually turning and yawning and
stretching that's when they actually get
up and start moving but he's waited so I
have a feeling that with only a matter
of time until them that are the other
ones gonna come along and then they're
gonna go on the hunt of the evening
which is so exciting it would be really
really really such a pleasure for me and
I really hope that they maybe get up
before you guys have to go which would
be awesome
now there are other vehicles with us
there are two others and that's the
light that you're seeing there but this
has been an absolute pleasure now you're
going to lift your head up to say
goodbye maybe you can give us a hug for
goodbyes no I'm asking too much
Aurore to say goodbye would be awesome
what do you say Villa
David you say this has been an amazing
Drive it truly has I mean when this guy
was rowing 7 I were high-fiving behind
the camera because it was awesome and he
is so close and that sound is so special
it's like nothing else stunning
well I think that I'll check on the
other male soon as well see if he's also
laying down and maybe they'll be looking
for the third brother that they're
calling for well I did hear the lion
contact calling back earlier so who
knows it's very very exciting but thank
you all of course for your questions and
your comments but is that time so see
you in the morning for the sunrise
Safari
[Music]